nos hemos encontrado en la ciudad de
Einstein es miedo y desconfianza miedo
porque los vecinos aseguran que les han
dejado regresar a sus casas pero nadie
les ha explicado detalles de Cómo deben
vivir su día a día es decir pueden lavar
la ropa con el agua corriente puede
entenderla como debe limpiar sus casas
para que el polvo no sea perjudicial
etcétera y desconfianza porque seguro
que se les está dando la información con
cuentagotas muy despacio y esto le está
generando mucha inseguridad y además
también temen por su salud No solamente
ahora en el presente sino cómo afectará
esto en un futuro Mientras tanto aquí
estamos viendo pues trabajadores de la
Epa que es la agencia de protección de
medio ambiente que revisan
constantemente los niveles de
contaminación en el aire con unos
pequeños aparatitos que han distribuido
por toda la localidad aseguran que los
niveles de contaminación no están por
encima de lo permitido pero de momento
Aquí sí que es verdad que nadie ha dicho
la palabra
muy pendientes también de lo que esté
ocurriendo en el agua porque se han
colocado unos diques unas especies de
serpientes alargadas color blanco para
poder limitar y que el agua contaminada
No siga no siga su curso río abajo
Además está tratando de limpiar este
agua porque se han reportado hasta el
pasado miércoles cerca de 3.500 veces
muertos Así mismo A pesar de que la Epa
asegure que los niveles de contaminación
son normales también Es verdad que
muchos vecinos aseguran que tienen
náuseas vómitos dolores de cabeza y
algunos picores y escozor en los ojos sí
que es verdad que en la localidad hay un
fuerte olor a goma quemada y que además
las autoridades están repartiendo en las
calles botellas de agua porque se
aconseja no beber todavía el agua
corriente hasta que se terminen los
exámenes en la mayoría de los pozos de
la localidad